be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so with Marvel releasing the trailer for
the upcoming defenders Netflix series
what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about the team and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of all this
you'll have a better understanding of
how it exists within Marvel Comics and
what to expect with regards to the
defenders Netflix series so the
defenders team first appeared in Marvel
Comics with Marvel Feature issue number
one in 1971 and was created by Roy
Thomas alongside artist Ross Andru
originally led by dr. strange and
consisting of the Hulk member the
Submariner and later Silver Surfer and
an interview with 2014 s comic Palooza
Roy Thomas had stated that with the
Avengers serving as a way for mobile to
roll various characters and as part of
the ongoing effort to introduce new
heroes as well as most of the popularity
of less popular heroes the characters of
Doctor Strange Hulk and others had
either served as part of the Avengers or
been included in Avengers stories which
saw the departure is final with no
indication of their return as a result
and because continuity was such a high
priority during this time Marvel's
mandate required their retcons take very
little precedence and instead emphasis
be placed on keeping the comic line
cohesive and easily understood using
this to capitalize on team-based books
which have been rising in popularity
owing to both the Fantastic Four and
Claremont's run on the x-men the
defenders were launched as a mini
Avengers of sorts providing a team for
characters who had previously been
written out of the Avengers but found
their solo series suffering to this end
and with issue number one covering the
team's origin the solo series of Doctor
Strange The Incredible Hulk and then
with the Submariner were cancelled out
and concluded in defenders issue number
one picking up with Doctor Strange
within his Greenwich Village home
strange is met with the telepathic
communications of an unknown being
following the voice to its source the
comic revealed that the voice was
emanating from Y and Roth a former
villain of Doctor Strange
who debuted in strange tales issue
number 164 to sidetrack for a second
with a strange tale line functioning as
an anthology series and featuring Doctor
Strange alongside other stories
involving the original Human Torch and
Nick Fury the stories of Doctor Strange
ran only 10 pages and included a litany
of experimental villains and an effort
to maintain the themes of Eastern
mysticism with classical superhero
archetypes
where the Doctor Strange line was wildly
popular among college students due to
their experimentation with mind altering
substances on the whole dr. strange was
relatively unpopular with most everyone
else as a result and in Marvel's efforts
to raise strangers profile a series of
extra dimensional beings were introduced
who fell in line with traditional
villain types taking place in a
five-part story between strange tales
issues 164 and 168 and Roth was
introduced as an extra dimensional
villain with a genius-level intellect
using his vast intelligence to seize
control of his home planet Yan and
expand his fear of influence into other
dimensions including earth-616 his
reality at the conclusion of the five
issue run Doctor Strange engaged in a
battle with the and Roth resulting in a
ladder falling over the edge and into
the dimension of Dreams a plane of
existence without end indicating the and
Roth would continue to fall for eternity
now picking up with the defenders line
with Doctor Strange arriving at the
hospital and discovering the and Roth
the store revealed that he had survived
by way of landing in a dimension beyond
his ability to understand but housing a
myriad of scientific artifacts for study
blending these concepts with his new
obsession for Magic II and Roth had
created a being known as the O Megatron
who would detonate every nuclear bomb in
the world following Andrus coming death
and listening the aid of name of the
Submariner by arguing the Earth's
destruction would include the Atlanteans
as well as offering himself as Hawks
friend in addition to glorious battle
strange Hulk and Namor traveled a point
promontory a village in New England
containing a lighthouse that held on
Megatron finding the facility to be
immune to the magic of Doctor Strange
the strength of name worn Hulk was used
to penetrate the facility after which
strange cast a spell that altered Omega
transperson of time as a result a mega
Tron would not activate the nuclear
missiles after the death of Y and Roth
and instead would wait several millennia
now again because this story was
designed to introduce the team the plot
of the story itself wasn't the driving
force so much as testing fan reception
to seeing a non Avengers team consisting
of some of Marvel's most popular heroes
all of whom worked together using a
combination of the letters page and
monthly sales to determine his
popularity because the series was so
well received the defenders line was
rolled over into his own solo
publication under the writing of Steve
Englehart and the artistry of salba
Simha
using the series as a way to retcon
portions of the Earth's history within
the realm of magic and mysticism Eagle
Hearts run in the first few comics
centered on the introduction of a group
of demons known as the undying ones led
by the nameless one all of which will
earth in its earlier history sometime
before the arrival of the Celestials and
the creation of mutants deviance and
Eternals at the same time and during an
article posted on his personal blog
Englehart had stated that the defenders
as they existed under the creation of
roy thomas could not hold longevity due
to the popularity of the characters
involved and the likelihood of them
being rolled over into future stories
and teams based on fandom and looking to
solve this problem Englehart expanded
the team's roster to include both Silver
Surfer and Valkyrie regarding Norrin
Radd where the Silver Surfer debuted as
part of the original Galactus trilogy in
Fantastic Four word issues 48 through 50
followed by a handful of subsequent
appearances in various backup features
because Marvel Comics served as a way to
experiment with various themes and
concepts in the late 60s and early 70s
the Silver Surfer received his own solo
series in 1968 written by Stan Lee and
drawn by Sal Buscema
released once a month and lasting a
total of 18 issues with Silver Surfer
having his own niche audience Engelhard
looked to bring those readers on board
adding to the melting pot of existing
fans and boosting the success of the
defenders line appearing in issue number
2 titled the search for the Silver
Surfer the story followed up to Norrin
Radd solo series and is exiled to earth
after turning against Galactus
recruiting the Silver Surfer to their
cause using Norns desire to prove his
worth in the eyes of humanity as well as
gain a better understanding of what it
meant to be a human the story of
Valkyrie is actually a little more
complex within Marvel Comics it is part
of the Asgardian landscape the character
of Valkyrie has largely operated as a
title to various women with each
iteration appearing as a means to
bolster the character using popular
titles at the time originally appearing
in Avengers number 70 through a
combination of retcons over the years
the existing history of al curry follows
that after incorporating earth into his
world tree Odin looked to honor the
souls of warriors who perished during
battle selecting a woman named Brunhilde
carry out this role Valkyrie operated as
the leader of a group called the
Valkyrie which functioned in a capacity
similar to angels of judeo-christianity
but with the themes of north mythology
escorting the souls of dead warriors to
Valhalla where they would spend eternity
celebrating their glorious battles
amongst the rest of the honored dead
while this remained the same
operations of Valkyrie at some point on
the line she drew the attention of amour
The Enchantress a strikingly beautiful
sorceress with incredible magical
abilities taking over the body of
Brunhilde with the intention of leading
a war against the Avengers while
enchantress was stopped during the
defenders battle against the undying
ones and chantry's had taken the mind of
a woman named Barbara Norris and swapped
her body with Brunhilde allowing Barbara
to operate as Valkyrie during her time
and the defenders fighting alongside
Doctor Strange Hulk and named work
following this Steve Englehart
orchestrated the Avengers defenders war
crossover with Avengers 1:16 through
1:18 and defenders issues 9 through 11
respectively considering on Loki and the
demon entity Dormammu working together
in an effort to conquer the earth which
would see the deaths of four and Doctor
Strange allowing Loki to seize control
of earth and door mama to take control
of the Year 6-1-6 dimension the two
tricked both the Avengers and the
defenders into believing that the other
look to capture the evil eye an
indestructible artifact capable of
manipulating matter on an atomic level
while the two teams were successful in
freeing themselves of loci and
dormammu's manipulations and driving
both beings back to their native
dimensions with Englehart focusing
heavily on the Avengers as well as
creating change he and various other
heroes issue number 11 saw him vacate
the title to be replaced by a handful of
riders between issues 12 and 19
including Len Wein and Chris Claremont
that said with a launch of giant sized
defenders number three going into issue
number 20 in 1975 writer Steve Gerber
took over the series offering a wholly
different style from his previous
contemporaries where Englehart set the
stage for the existing team which was
capitalized on by the various riders
following his departure Gerber
maintained these popular themes but look
to use the series as a way to return
formerly lost or unpopular heroes to the
mama landscape in the same capacity as
the Avengers in Captain America to this
end and during his twenty one issue run
Gerber's time saw the defenders
encountering the original iteration of
the guardians of the galaxy as that were
created in 1969 as well as the 1950's
anthology characters the headsman where
these concepts were extremely well
received by comic fans behind the scenes
Gerber's time on the title was fraught
with delays and missed deadlines this
coupled with his 1978 lawsuit against
Marvel regarding his creation of Howard
the Duck saga removed from all model
imprints resulting in the series falling
into several writers hands until issue
number 48 after which it was taken over
by David Anthony Kraft taking the series
in a more comedic line not unlike Mary
Jo Duffy's run of Power Man and Iron
Fist David Anthony crafts time on the
defenders title was met with polarizing
views between traditional fans who
wanted things to stay the same and
existing fans who wanted something new
while the negative reception wasn't
overt in the sense of fans writing in by
the droves crafts time on the series
only lasted around 20 issues and
included an expansion on the story about
curry after which the series was handed
over to a series of successive riders
between issue number 66 in 1979 and
issue number 91 1981 including Steve
grant and Ed Hannigan and so going into
the early 80s letter jmd Mateus remained
on the series until it's cancellation
with issue number 125 at the same time
because the defenders line is seen a
modest increase among its members
growing to include Hellcat Patsy Walker
Nighthawk instead of Satan Mateus
performed double duty on the first half
of its run performing cleanup duty in
terms of the plot threads left behind by
David Anthony crafts and Steve grant as
well as continuing to create compelling
stories involving the team as a whole
however as a writer who spent a majority
of his time crafting short horror
stories for DC Mateus adapted well to
the light-hearted and sometimes comedic
stories of the defenders assuring end
when many considered to be the best run
on the series on the other hand where
Mateus saw in expands on the series
itself his drive to create something of
his own accord saw the defenders line
rebooted in 1983 under the name the new
defenders removing the original lineup
of Doctor Strange Silver Surfer name of
the Submariner and Hulk and place of
Beast Iceman Warren Worthington and moon
dragon while the series saw a massive
boost in sales owing in part to the
incorporation of characters from Chris
Claremont x-men during a 1986 interview
with former editor-in-chief Jim salic
Rev Mateus had stated that instead of
having a team with a hodgepodge of
members with virtually nothing in common
he had essentially transformed the
defenders into a conventional superhero
team that fell rank-and-file with the
existing model line of titles vacating
his position as writer after six issues
and handing the series over to Peter
Gillis the relaunch brand ultimately
flattered entirely
finding itself cancelled after only 12
issues following this model stayed
relatively hands-off the defenders until
1993 when editor-in-chief Tom DeFalco
how the series reinstated
under the moniker of secret defenders in
a sidetrack here while I haven't been
able to find an exact reason for this I
would argue that with comic readers a
new shooting the busts of the 1990s and
sending sales to a virtual all-time low
model looked to relaunch virtually any
brand with any measure of previous
popularity in the hopes that the series
would help lift the company out of his
reverie and road to bankruptcy removing
the traditional superhero element of the
team and replacing it with a strike
force format which fell in line with a
high octane and fast paced comics of the
time the secret defenders line saw
Doctor Strange place in the role of
leader and the defenders operating as an
overarching name for various iterations
of different teams all of which were
assembled by strange for various
missions to be carried out in secret
where the series proved to be lackluster
especially after dr. Strange's removal
from the line in lieu of placement as
part of the midnight sons title which
included Michael Morbius and world wolf
by night the secret defenders line was
canceled with issue number 25 that said
with Joe Quesada Green brought on board
as editor in chief in 2001 as part of
his multi-year plan to reinvigorate
Marvel and bring the company back to his
classical roots the defenders received a
12 issue miniseries under the writing of
her Busic and Erik Larsson spinning out
into another six-issue miniseries titled
the order which saw the return of Y and
Roth and defenders themselves taking a
more dictatorial approach regarding the
relationship to the world at large the
story wasn't outright bad so much as it
lacked the Flair the fans had grown
accustomed to regarding the traditional
team at the same time and in the eyes of
fans the early 2000s were a point of
fluctuation among existing readers and
now with the exception of Grant
Morrison's new x-men almost all titles
seem to fall short of expectations in
terms of the storage from the 1990s
versus the storage of the time as a
result in the years leading up to civil
war the defenders only received one
miniseries under the writing of Keith
Griffin J M DeMatteis
and Kevin Maguire which took a dark
humor approach but didn't really offer
anything that hadn't been seen before
now in terms of Civil War while I do
have a discussion on the full event in
the nature of its contents I've never
really offered much in the way of an
explanation on the aftermath
where this was largely due to the fact
that spending three months talking about
civil war was enough to turn me off to
anything that had anything to do with
the series in 2008 under writer Joe
Casey the defenders were returned to the
landscape of Marvel Comics as part of
the fifty state initiative as it was
created by Reed Richards Tony Stark
decide track for a second where the
Civil War event itself focused on the
conflict between Tony Stark and Captain
America over freedom versus security the
underlying current was the fifty state
initiative and the idea of shield
overseeing all superhero activity and
placing a team in each state as a means
to guarantee of security as a result in
following Captain America's surrender
followed by its arrest under the
direction of Tony Stark as director of
shield the fifty state initiative was
implemented with the defenders operating
out of New Jersey and compose of
Colossus she-hulk Nighthawk and blazing
skull receiving almost universally
negative reviews the six-issue
miniseries saw the last appearance of
the traditional defenders team until
2011 when the group was reformed during
the events of fear itself written by
Matt Fraction and coming out as one of
several times to the larger feared self
story the 2011 iteration of the
defenders focus on the team's
Reformation under dr. strange during
Earth's battle against the serpent a
former ask Guardian claiming to be the
rightful heir to the throne of Asgard
format fractions run until the inclusion
of black hat Nick Fury and Scott Lang
the miniseries served as a retcon
indicating that the defenders series was
a lost cause what I mean here is that
because the order miniseries revealed
that the formation of the original
defenders would lead to a chain reaction
which would destroy the universe at some
point in the future Matt Fraction retcon
the team out of existence by having
Doctor Strange invoked the powers of the
vishanti
by traveling to a point in the past
wiping the team out of existence by
preventing their original formation and
eliminating all successive events from
Marvel's continuity as a result and
going to the start of Marvel's secret
wars with the exception of Colin buns
misty Knight led team which used the
defenders name the traditional role of
the team as it existed prior to map
fractions run had no involvement in the
Marvel Universe of any kind now with
that said in terms of the Netflix series
you've most likely noticed that there
seems to be virtually no connection of
any kind between the team as it exists
in the comics and the version will see
with Jessica Jones Luke Cage iron fist
and daredevil while this seems to come
out of left field in a 2015 interview
with cinema blend Joe Quesada had stated
that because the defenders team was so
obscure outside of only the most
hardcore fans of the series the concept
of the defenders lent itself to a
reimagining within the MCU as a
street-level superhero team which would
largely go without much fuss from those
looking to see daredevil and the rest of
the Netflix lineup come together as her
own band of men
Avengers now whether or not the
defenders will actually crossover with
the Avengers themselves has yet to be
seen but if what's coming out of the
rumor mill is to be believed the
infighting between the movie and
television arm will likely prevent any
crossover between the two especially
considering the forthcoming events of
the larger MCU regarding Adam warlock
Thanos and the Infinity Gauntlet with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and if you guys
enjoyed this video on the defenders make
sure you guys drop a like on the video
and I'll catch you guys later peace